is there a god ah no we're both a theist
I want you look like a knight this you
look like the lead singer of a Christian
band okay I'm not an atheist I'm kind of
open to lots of things a theist I get I
like them I'll enjoy that as one of the
options I'm a big I think the the
problem is a lot of Christians were the
atheists that we're just going to be
animals and we're going to be bad people
because we don't have any restrictions
but you know it's the life is just try
not to be a that's that's all life is
they said I could swear in this show but
they didn't say what word they said some
words are good I assumed that one wasn't
on your list um I'm I'm kind of excited
to get our first in there and that's not
something that you would normally hear
from the frontman doors of clay you know
what's great about this but is you and I
it'll never end no no most of that lair
but we know where it ended we had that
beautiful flourish ending I'll fix my
scarf now we're just fixing scarves yeah
this is a pre-recorded scan going all
day there's already been a guy that's
held out the sign that said wrap yeah
it might have been a guy that went he
might have just been getting his lunch
order in Spencer just wanted to tell us
what you had for luck